hello everybody my name is markiplier
and i would like to officially welcome
you
to laundros i could do laundry
while i record my videos thereby saving
me
all the time in the world
what okay so i was gonna be recording in
that room that you probably saw that
other video recorded in maybe some other
videos
but it hurt my back to sit on the floor
so i'm standing now
anyway you guys are probably wanting a
house tour so i'm going to give you one
it's just not going to be my house
i'm watching this video called my house
walkthrough amy told me about this one
it's apparently just an unbelievably
unsettling video and i don't know how a
house tour can be unsettling
but we're about to find out
so i think the story was that this was
like recorded after a flood or something
or a tsunami came
it's it's like japan a typhoon is in
japan
and this is my room
oh my god
i don't know what the hina doll room is
this is altar and ancestors
picture from around the time why does
this all look
so terrifying
when i open this there's another hallway
okay right room is the doll room
this room was closed up by my
grandfather
okay was that the hema doll room that
you were talking about
it's a picture of my mother when she was
a child why is everything
so grimy like everything is just
caked in grime
this is weird it's my great grandmother
what
is wrong with her face wait a minute
hold on a second
am i am i being horrifically
disrespectful or was there something
wrong with the face there
hmm no i thought these might have been
eyes but
i still don't like it okay sorry
everybody
turn left there's another hallway
this is a bathroom
this rubs me all kinds of the wrong way
i hear a sutra what's a sutra
my grandfather is always listening to
sutra from the radio what does that mean
i don't know what that is where are you
going the wall peels off from the
ceiling when it rains
oh that's bad
okay this is the longest hallway in my
house
how many hallways are in your house
[Music]
i don't like that string
wait a minute a typhoon is in japan this
is my room
the tatami mats are terribly damaged
what what what
what when i open this with some so
there's another oh wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
that's a picture for me what the
hell is happening oh
the left room is the dress room was that
blood
okay room was closed up by my
grandfather when i turn left at the end
there's another hallway sure there is
of course there is enough that this is
new
it's the longest hole in my all right
his grandmother's bedroom are you sure
it's not the doll room
it was closed up by my grandfather yeah
okay
oh oh oh when i opened up
there's another hallway yeah
oh the roof leaks yeah the walls peel
off
what in the hell is god what was it what
an agency
like what is it what is even in the
coloring in this video
i've never seen anything like this i've
never seen a place with like shadows as
deep as this place
this makes no sense when i turn left and
then there's another hallway
no there's not
oh this is bathroom
ratness above the ceiling
among other things maybe this is the
longest hallway in my house yeah i know
i know did i see
hair on the wall to the right there
whenever there is another hallway
pull peels off in this oh
oh
room is the dress room oh the dress
room's open now
oh good a lot of dress for me is that
blood
oh
my grandmother is not here the holes
eaten by insects have turned black like
blood stains
yeah much like those bloodstains
immediately
hi grandmother's mannequin okay
this is doll room
decades yep
yep yeah it is it sure has
the wall piece i don't like that the
camera and the flashlight are separated
i'm used to playing video games like
this where it's all stuck together
oh grandma mother and grandfather hey
grampy
come off to the end there's another
hallway yeah
yeah there is
how
grandfather i was listening to sutra
from i still don't know what suture is
hi grandma
something was definitely wrong with the
face there but i'm not going to go back
and check because i don't want to
who's wrong with the painting
[Music]
oh
no no
no one has been in this room for a very
long time
what these dolls are rotten
huh emperor stahl's run too
grandmother is not here no i don't
expect that she would be
it'd be really worrying if she was
this alter ancestors
hi the paintings are a little
damaged from the storm
another oh god
no oh
is that hair what is that on the left
what is what's that painting
what is it in the hallway this is
grandma's bedroom
i thought it was closed off didn't
grampy say no go in there
room has no taste oh yeah no it's
horrid decorations grandma just was
not about it scratches on the walls
great grandmother's shoes
great grandmother's here
oh huh many mouse turds okay yeah that's
the least see your problems man
that's the least of your problems
grandmother
grandfather is not here well
grandfather's about to be here i think
hi grandma
oh
there's another hallway sure there is
sure of course there is
another hallway looks like the wiring
has been pulled out of the walls that's
great
hi
hair did i see hair i saw here another
hallway
yeah uh-huh oh yeah you gotta get that
cleaned up man that don't look so good
oh something was in your sink
i'm gonna ignore all the bugs and wall
on the walls because that's
oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh it's fine it's a door
oh great everything is coated
this is great
oh this is good stuff grandfather's
always listening to the sutra
oh grampy oh grampy bambi
you silly nonsense person this is the
longest hallway in my house
is that the sound of the sutra
sound of wind woke me up in the middle
of the night a typhoon is in japan
ceiling is rotten and falling away
[Music]
oh
holes eating the insects have turned
black like blood stains yeah
how hot no one has been in this room for
very long you're in the hallway
what's the sound this is my room this is
a hallway
[Music]
oh
sweet dreams
[Music]
making of my house mother i don't want
to know
that was one of the most ridiculously
scary things i've seen in a long time
there's something about this that like
throws me this was released in 2016.
this is easily one of the scariest
things i've ever seen and i've seen a
lot of very scary things
there's something so unbelievably
unsettling about this
the seemingly normal nature of the video
content and yet the absolute horror of
going through this goddamn house
i mean you could compare it to certain
things like say pt going through
hallways and seeing things change but
this took it to another level like this
still could do a complete other level
and this is where kind of like
sometimes uh the video content works
better for horror than like games do
because games like
with pt and playing that you do get a
sense of complacency of like oh you get
to relax because you're like oh this all
looks the same i don't know what's going
on this was just terrifying from start
to finish
it was 12 minutes of horrifying it was
12 minutes of i am cursed and i'm gonna
die in seven days
that's what that was that's what that
did i haven't gotten that for many games
i
i fee it's because it's so real right
it's because it feels real like this was
just something that someone uploaded
and it's cursed forever and every one of
us is cursed for watching it that's what
it feels like
so anyway links in the description watch
this alone
without me here i dare you
i double dare you and then come back
here and comment if you survived
but only if you survived good luck to
you out there
anyway i am starting filming for uh
heist 2 starting tomorrow
so that should be very fun and i can't
wait to get started on i can't wait to
show you guys things
get look forward to a lot more videos in
the laundrofis
you know i don't think i can do a tour
as good as this video but
hey take it all in
enjoy it this is our home now this is
our home for a while
and frankly it's actually better than a
lot of offices i've had
so yeah thank you everybody so much for
watching click the link in the
description to see this video
good luck